despite many considering him as the best
tekken player in the world knee has
fallen short from getting the evo world
championship in america in the past few
years
he does it safe evo 2016 checking seven
fbr champions again this could be it
shoulder one mix up could do it
oh man
oh and there it is it was a tall organ
was
crazy so first on
the evil trick blows oh
man that was a crazy trade arsenal
cementing his position as the best
second player
2022 was different though after a
two-year hiatus to offline evo knee
would make a statement in one of the
most dominating performances we've ever
seen from a tekken player
once again my name is drew and this is
knee's perfect run in evo 2022
[Music]
uh
wow look at me though
[Applause]
double rage give it his rage drive today
that was a good round
dude
he's a monster yeah he's not
scared unrelenting that is the crazy
part against the brian player where
you're thinking to yourself i don't want
to get counted here because every
counter is a launcher but this sense
does not care
holy moly knee has come to play
raise your belly but now for knee
that will counter hit no bro
the one that makes it through the one
grab after a good start from the pools
knee would also make short work to top
16 securing his spot on top eight's
winner's side using fang
yep
oh blue shoulder
oh my gosh
lee the movement the pokemon
dude
[Music]
the defense and that is three rounds
straight easy as you like do your right
that's facing watch me move me right now
oh
[Music]
shut up
straight away not letting kenya even
breathe right now that's 50 god back for
just stopping all of his offense oh
that's it that's it that's it he's head
he's dead he has to be oh
what is happening right now dominance
from knee as he moves into tomorrow's
top eight at the arena on the winner's
side evo 2024. welcome everyone to evo
2022 tekken 7 top 8 my name is rip i'm
strapped here and i'm here with
my name is aris nice to talk to you guys
[Music]
against all the top players knee is
looking ridiculous like a robot a
machine whatever you want to call it but
we'll see oh my god
the follow-up is he dead is he dead the
ranger has come in no he decides to save
it he's got the time involved
he's so good he's behind here on life 10
seconds left to go in this round good
look at the side step in there down back
three counter itself five seconds on the
clock the times are waiting he does have
the likely knees starting to pull away
what's happening
and he blocked it down four at the end
he played here unexpected he has two
meters you better use it or lose it
again time went down knee with the big
lead look at this sidestep
oh he threw through hate through he's
wasting time he's not running
no way five seconds
let's see what happens
again he's got going backwards this is a
very nice backswing blow from the kenpo
step
no throw break only one plus two oh he's
nervous he's not ready for it let's see
what happens knee is with a huge lead
here but moyle he does that rage that's
happening
does so much damage if he landed he's
about to get the meter never never mind
never never mind knee got this under
control do it again do it again again
another thing i was unusual to me me
using hopkins
trying to build these up too he's not
gonna get the punish there me right now
looking to close it out but there's rain
time again back four fish shook up any
big opening he's not letting him have
nothing bad temple steps and that will
be enough me 2-0 over moyo
on the other hand is in the loser's side
and slowly climbing his way back to
grand finals with many anticipating a
rematch from way back to evo 2019 where
knee fell short in the grand finals
what's gonna happen right now knee
looking for this opportunity
holding my breath
oh
the trade blows oh
oh
man that was a crazy trade arseland
[Music]
moves like a rage drive he doesn't have
quick ways to get in and pressure his
opponent he has to play off fundamentals
and that's gonna be so hard to do
against steve caught seven seconds full
bar again that same situation get in
he's been at this time he's chipping
away he's going in down four again
nothing the fish hook is right on time
now life leading favor of khan this is
where the tables are turned in now to
make the approach great here we go final
round game one if he gets a nice solid
hit exactly i don't think he's gonna
have an opening that's the thing need
rarely leaves an opening for that kind
of stuff you gotta fish you just gotta
fish and believe he's going for it
15 seconds now it's gonna go down below
check for sure oh
back in up
yo me how do you do that he backed up
like you're gonna move forward
be careful there is a wall in play but
look at that just maneuvering besides
that blow perry that was oh yeah the
step he sidestepped up down forward for
the low berry yeah good stuff knee up
with the presence of mind really able to
capitalize gets the hit this is big oh
positioning though that is very key and
now khan keeping that pressure oh he
floated him out of the portable plus two
you're not swiping me swiping no swiping
counter though con closing out the round
there you go easy combo right
for the round win
watch this cinema pick them apart
rage mode for condo and almost two
minutes back it up
he's gonna do backswings and reverse
kenpos that is a key that works so well
against that downpour too oh the
flashcal
oh he dropped the combo mark this is not
good
he's going to rage
don't back it up maybe he just won it
right oh boy
do you back it up
blue stuff it's blocked
can't believe it he looked up like how
did i lose that dude just do it just
believe max voting go smash ball to go
off this down he
starting to open up with pressure yeah
he's starting to use some of the tools
that has been the killer of the story
during there's so many things that he
can oh my god oh my goodness one plus
two clutch with me the follow-up there's
gonna be a mix-up here what's the mix he
goes for a quickie easy he got him he's
there
[Applause]
[Applause]
and look at this he's trying to get
knees throughout that period again
how is he this good with that move i
don't know
but khan right now he's got raising two
meters apiece he's gonna do it again
he's he's aiming for it of course at the
pixel
d powered
not gonna happen today
knee two to one now combo
hey oh yes rachel out here
oh man
goes for the mid to follow up here
counter down back three better guess
right oh he might be pleased where's the
sidewall same though the jab conversion
he's got rage defendant
why didn't you spend it
oh my god oh my gosh what are we doing
yo god
he is trying so hard
oh beautiful precise hop kick there from
knee
knee is so ready his reaction is on
point
wow no wall stretch good throw break
though
khan has a meter to work with
very close oh deducted they flashed each
other what's going to happen ball to a
jab the devin did nothing
oh my goodness the backboard the vicious
oh he's delayed yeah nice punish gets
the knock down the follow-up as well got
some extra damage
oh what are you doing that could have
been the worst mistake we've seen in
this setup that's huge but he still has
a big lead big lead and a bar meter knee
chipping back away at this lead though
he could have had the winning mix up
though it could have been it could have
been but it's not it's dead knees almost
gone up the counter the wall's right
there though he's gonna lift last chance
caught down to
me he's going to the grand finals of evo
2022
khan though would put an end to this
anticipation as he would beat arsene in
the losers final three games to one
leading up to another meeting with knee
in the grand finals on the line god to
eliminate arsenal arthur without a raise
in the background aaron
that'll do it
is eliminated from evil han will be
moving on to the grand finals
evo 2022 and seven
east houses
people want to be gone they're pretty
loud
yo 10 seconds it's gonna be so dangerous
beautiful stuff we owe the conversion
beautiful absolutely beautiful
despite khan's amazing gameplay of geese
all throughout the tournament ni's
defense and poking a fang was just too
much for him
he's gonna put himself in good position
goes for the mix of sidestep
and he's looking so dejected right now
he can't believe he let that happen to
himself
yeah let the lead just chill 14 seconds
in this set one of the things is that
tron has changed instead of letting me
just control pages single jab he's
ducked and punched with while standing
for that time the down three there right
so to stop him from ducking those high
jabs you know he's throwing out a lot
more mids with that down four three to
really make it pay for it full meter
pecan here way behind on life though and
time beginning to wind down i mean how
often do you see east locked in with
three full meters it's very rare that we
can see that nice follow-up there three
three down four and one into the
following combo
oh there's tight seconds left
trying to fade it back tenfold eight
seconds ready to go do it ready go do it
force mix these beautiful side steps and
that's the game
nicely done
[Music]
all right here comes the jab and again
don't be down between and con down he's
already adapted back to it and there's a
punch counter from me
and here we go combo conversion not
going to reach the wall this will be a
little bit short
oh my gosh he's pissing at the wall oh
he keeps him there yeah
thirteen seconds knee with a small like
lead
khan has not fit good in time magic
situation now the time god oh what a
whiff on it to get the story of the
matchup you've seen reverse campbell and
reverse miss two and you hold these
punches that's my round
that's there's the down four three
making his return
beautiful from the
it's like all right you got it around
you stole it
not again at least he's not in race this
time right but he has meters that's the
thing he has the wall position
the wall's gonna save him here
he missed the shoulder yeah he hit the
second butt but the back temple steps
there to cover him like don't worry i
still got this button
i throw break here against the range
again
two more rounds and we're gonna have an
evil champion i can't go into
[Music]
oh he's gonna happen he's gonna get a
wall break as well
no it's already gone it's already gone
time though
plenty of time big lively beneath that
should have been back week two that was
the chance he goes for the throw
so much pressure something's gonna
happen
too
again he missed me he had two chances
there he had two jedi so close to
winning the championship
but the meter you get so much better
keys he's the meter king he's betting
here's the mix 10 seconds about left
right now he's close he's got one more
mark he can be champion in five seconds
he's got the lead he's got the lead he's
going to do it 63 one knee is yours
tekken 7 champion and evil 2022
congratulations knee south korea and
tekken fans around the world
what a championship saying
oh my god
beautiful
beautiful
oh my goodness
after so many years
so many years of trying to win this
tournament he has finally done it
this game came out about the 2017. it's
five six years later he had him up i'm
not really trying to do that match lee
finally getting his championship great
stuff what an amazing session
after nine years finally claims the
championship for his very first evo
championship in tekken 7.
your evil 2022
tekken 7
champion
from korea put your hands up for me
disappearing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the sky is
[Music]
if you enjoyed the video please leave a
like and subscribe to our channel tv
thanks for watching
[Music]
south korea's cafe team takes it
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right his first evil title
give it up guys
[Music]
you